[Music]
Denise Richards burst onto the scene
with a steamy kiss and wild things but
it wouldn't be the last time she
attracted attention from late 90s it
girl to only fanstar the real housewife
has always managed to keep things
interesting
in 1998 Denise Richards starred in the
sleazy classic Wild Things her three-way
kiss with Nev Campbell and Matt Dillon
was a prominent draw for audiences but
the film holds other twists and delights
besides all the smooching red sheds
played Kelly van Ryan in the film a
wealthy and popular girl who accuses
guidance counselor Sam Lombardo of
statutory rape the two girls admit to
falsifying their accusations on the
stand which prompts Lombardo to sue
Kelly's family for a significant chunk
of change from there things get twistier
and twistier everyone is an accomplice
on the grift and everyone backstabs
everyone else it's high melodrama
in 1999 Denise Richards co-starred
opposite Kirsty alley in drop dead
gorgeous the deadpan mockumentary was
about a small town beauty pageant and a
series of horrific murders committed in
pursuit of its Crown the film is now
considered a cult classic but was
underseen upon initial release Richards
played Becky Lehman the presumed
favorite in the team beauty pageant
contest oh my God lights camera and me
without a stitch of makeup on
unfortunately for Richard 1999 was also
the year she co-starred in the World is
Not Enough starring Pierce Brosnan as
James Bond Richards played nuclear
physicist Christmas Jones in the film
but her role was universally panned by
critics Yahoo's James Bond blog even had
this to say about Richard's part look of
any Pole or column from recent years on
the worst Bond girls ever and Dr
Christmas Jones comes up every time Dr
Christmas Jones came to represent all
the cheese that made bond fans sour on
the Brosnan films
so in a way Denise Richards is partially
to thank for the grittier Daniel Craig
version of the character
during the 2000s and early 2010s Denise
Richards film career kind of put it out
her biggest roles post Bonds were mostly
cameos and prominent films people
remember her 10 seconds and Love
Actually better than her starring role
in deep in the valley at the very end of
the Christmas classic Richard's
character travels to England to meet Sad
Sack Colin's best friend however one of
her most memorable guest appearances was
on a controversial seventh season
episode of Friends in which she played
Cassie Geller this episode crossed a
major line for many friends fans but
Ross tried to kiss Cassie Ross even had
this lame explanation for his actions I
I haven't had sex in a very long time
Grantland Sam Hockley Smith even cites
the episodes of one where the show
jumped the shark
in 2002 Richards married Charlie Sheen
their courtship started normally enough
but things took a turn shortly after
Richards became pregnant with a couple's
second daughter Lola Rose Sheen in 2005
Richard separated from Sheen while she
was still pregnant with Lola she later
saw to restraining order against him
citing threats had allegedly made
against a life Richards found ways to
Parlay her fracturing personal life into
work by starring in the reality show
Denise Richards it's complicated in 2008
and Publishing her Memoir in 2011 in the
Memoir she talks about Sheen's sudden
transformation into someone she did not
trust yeah
yeah I I am on a drug it's called
Charlie Sheen she told the Huffington
Post the man I fell in love with is very
compassionate humble has a wonderful
heart and the behavior that a lot of us
saw in the last six months is not the
person that I met and fell in love with
in 2018 Richards joined the cast of The
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
Richards was an all of season nine but
left season 10 prematurely after Brandy
Glanville asserted that the two had
hooked up when Richards refused to
return for season 11 no one was very
surprised the show's executive producer
Andy Cohen told people the negotiations
broke down overpay but Richard said that
she wanted to spend time with people
that actually liked her A source told
people she was looking to replace Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills was time
loving her amazing husband children and
who knows maybe even friends now
in addition to her acting career Denise
Richards is also an accomplished model
she started modeling as a teenager and
was successful enough to travel the
world for photo shoots and commercials
once her acting career took off she
spent less time modeling but still made
time to pose in the gala Christmas issue
of Playboy magazine in 2004. red shields
had given birth to her oldest daughter
Sammy just months before the photo shoot
her husband at the time Charlie Sheen
was a Playboy fan and encouraged her to
be in the magazine but she had her own
reasons for doing it as well Richard's
revealed to US Weekly in 2011 I wanted
to encourage women that it's okay to
embrace your sexuality even though
you're a mom
Richards has gone through so many highs
and lows that is hard to keep up with it
all luckily for her fans she released
her Memoir the real girl next door which
ended up becoming a New York Times
bestseller the book dives into topics
like a tumultuous marriage with Charlie
Sheen the moment she realized they
needed a divorce and adjusting to life
as a single mom however she has insisted
that the book isn't meant to bash her
ex-husband and it doesn't reveal the
most private details of her life she
told radar online I went through a whole
lot and I get asked a lot of questions
about that time in my life so I figured
I would write my story and hopefully
anyone that has been you know dealing
with challenges will know that there is
light at the end of the tunnel
Richard's adopted her daughter Eloise in
2011 and began raising her as a single
mom but things changed when Richards
tied the knot with Aaron Pipers in 2018.
just got married
he began helping Richards raise her
three daughters and adopted Eloise when
she was seven years old Eloise has had
some developmental delays due to a rare
disorder known as chromosome eight known
asomi 8p which is characterized by a
partial deletion of the eighth
chromosome Richards discovered the news
after she noticed Eloise wasn't reaching
milestones at the typical rate such as
learning how to walk and talk drawing an
emotional reunion on the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills Richard said that the
diagnosis was hard on the family despite
the challenges that come with this
disorder Richards and Vipers have
remained committed to finding the best
medical care for Eloise no matter what
parts of redshirt's transformation over
the years has been a result of plastic
surgery and cosmetic procedures in a
memoir she explained that she's had four
breast augmentation surgeries which has
added that she got her first surgery at
just 19 years old because she thought
her acre breasts went big enough for
Hollywood she was in such a rush to get
the surgery that she didn't properly
research doctors and unfortunately she
ended up with bigger implants than she
wanted the second surgery was meant to
reduce her breast size but the doctor
went against her wishes and gave her
even bigger implants the third surgery
finally reduced her breast size and the
fourth replaced the implants after they
ruptured she has also tried Botox saying
she loved how the results looked but
didn't like the way they made her face
feel since then Richards has been
avoiding Botox and fillers in fact she
has claimed that she's never used
fillers some people thought she did in
2019 but she said she just gained weight
due to a thyroid issue
so how does Richards maintain a youthful
appearance without Botox and fillers
it's simple she takes great care of her
skin her passion for skin care led her
to create CB me Beauty a line of pimp
infused skin care products in a 2020
Interview With Us Weekly Rich has
explained I'm in front of the camera so
I do want to take very good care of my
skin and that's also why I thought it
would be a great time to venture to have
my own skin line the skincare line
consists of six products including a
hydrating cream moisturizer and eye
cream Richard's personal favorite she
said is a hydrating moisturizer made
with hemp oil in her interview with US
Weekly she said she plans to expand the
line with new products that contain CBD
and other cannabinoids
in 2022 Sheen and Richard's then 18 year
old daughter Sammy joined only fans a
site that allows users to sell nude
photos and videos for their subscribers
Richards thought it was unfair that
Sammy was getting so much backlash so a
week later she joined the site as well
to support her daughter I always think
it's good for kids to have a passion
sheen on the other hand was very opposed
to his daughter joining only fans he
even blamed Richards for Sammy's actions
since they were living together at the
time Richard said that all she could do
was try to guide Sami but at the end of
the day she makes her own decisions on a
more positive note Richard said during a
2022 interview with the radio show Jeff
Lewis live but making it only fans
account has been very lucrative for her
so you were shocked when you got your
first checked she posts content that's a
bit more revealing than what she can
post on Instagram and said she has full
ownership of what she shares which she
finds empowering Richards has helped
many Charities over the years in 2006
she did a nude photo shoot for Jane
magazine to support the clothes off our
back Foundation which helps children all
around the world live better lives she
collaborated with ShoeDazzle multiple
times in 2012 to design high heels and
raise money for the kidney cancer
Association successfully raising over
fifteen thousand dollars in the process
she has also been a huge supporter of
Best Friends Animal Society fostering
kittens with the help of her daughters
and raising awareness about the benefits
of adopting animals she even paid for
several rescue dogs medical care nurse
them back to health and adopted them
Richard stayed busy after leaving the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills in 2020
Landing many different roles on TV shows
perhaps most notably she played fun
single mom Shauna Fulton on The Bold and
the Beautiful for several years in the
series paper Empire she portrays a
wealthy woman whose opulent lifestyle
gets turned upside down when her husband
gets arrested the show is set to
Premiere in 2024. Richards also
portrayed CIA agent Laura Lois and the
Guardians of Justice
puns were disappointed when Denise
Richards left the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills in season 10 but she's
officially returning to the show for
season 13. her return was so unexpected
that even the production crew didn't
know about it until it happened Richards
randomly showed up at a screening
because she's friends with real
housewife Cassel Beauvais and then the
crew asked her to attend some events
from there she started getting more
involved Richards told Variety in 2023 I
have filmed some episodes and it's been
fun and you know I'm a big fan of the
show so it was fun to go back and film a
lot of stuff with them Richards has
confirmed that she won't be in season
13's promo shots so it seems like she'll
be returning as a guest there was a lot
of drama and negativity surrounding
Richard's exit from the show in 2020 but
she says things were different this time
around she told variety that she didn't
get caught up in the drama and had fun
with the whole experience rather than
letting others get her down